the best performance by an actress in
the supporting role the nominees are
Ingrid Bergman in Murder on the Orient
Express
Valentina Court Asia and day for night
Madeline Kahn in Blazing Saddles Diane
Ladd and Alice doesn't live here anymore
Talia Shire in The Godfather Part two
and the winner is the winner is Ingrid
Bergman in the Murder on the Orient
Express
thank you very much indeed it's always
very nice to get an Oscar but in the
past in the past he has shown that he is
very forgetful then also has the wrong
timing because last year when day and
night one for the best picture I
couldn't believe it that Valentina
Cortez was not nominated because he gave
the most beautiful performance yeah
she gave the most beautiful performance
that all reactors is recognized because
after all we have all forgotten our
lines and always opened the wrong doors
and it was wonderful to see her do it so
beautifully therefore I am it's so
ironic that this year she's nominated
when the picture won last year I don't
quite understand that but here I am and
I'm her arrival and I don't like it at
all please forgive me Valentina I didn't
mean to